الصراع في السودان يفتح باب مواجهه جديده
بين روسيا والغرب وموسكو تكشف رسميا ولاول
مره عن دور مجموعه فاغنر هناك وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ومن المقر الاممي في
نيويورك كشف ان للسودان الحق في الاستفاده
من خدمات فاغنر فضلا عن كلام لافروف رئيس
فارنير اكد استعداد مجموعته للتدخل في حال
طلب الشعب السوداني ذلك
يطلب الشعب السوداني فسارسل بالتاكيد مهمه
حفظ سلام الى السودان من قبل شركه فاجنر
العسكريه الخاصه ولو كانت فاجنر هناك
اعتقد ان الحرب لم تكن لتبدا في السودان
فاجنر لا تبدا الحروب انما تنهيها دائما
لكن كيف تطورت العلاقات السودانيه الروسيه
وصولا الى تعزيز دور باكنير موسكو اسست
لوجودها في السودان منذ عهد البشير من
خلال تحسين شروط عمل شركات الطاقه الروسيه
واخرى تنشط في مجال التنقيب عن الذهب
والثروات الاخرى ايضا ابرز ما عزز الوجود
الروسي في السودان هو السلاح الذي اصبحت
بسببه المصدر الرئيسي للجيش السوداني
فتحولت الخرطوم الى ثاني شريك عسكري
لروسيا في القاره الافريقيه بعد الجزائر
بعد تلك الخطوات وتحديدا عام 2017 وقع
السودان اتفاقا مع روسيا لانشاء قاعده
عسكريه على البحر الاحمر تستضيف سفنا
روسيه بما في ذلك سفن تعمل بالوقود النووي
على ان يتمركز فيها 300 جندي اتفاق
خلق الغرب بدوره في تعزيز الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه في افريقيا وعلى سواحل البحر
الاحمر
ورغم وقف العمل بالاتفاقيه بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير الى ان مصالح موسكو في السودان
دفعتها الى الابقاء على علاقه وثيقه مع
اللاعبين الاساسيين خلال السنوات الماضيه
لكن تميزت مع احمدتي خصوصا على خلفيه
تزايد التقارير حول امداد قواته بالسلاح
والمساعده العسكريه الروسيه من خلال قوات
فاغنر محاسن حضاره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات